yeah and especially once they run out of
like actual targets you find them
like if you look at some of the stuff
that's been going on where they go
you know how jk rowling's got cut down
or whatever right yeah
like they would agree with her on 99.9
of stuff yep and it was like you don't
comply for the extra one percent and
that's kind of not enough like
there was that one hey you got to burn
something huh well exactly but there was
a new one with uh
lizzo and she basically came out i
always said lizzle is a huge inspiration
to the fat gross community
but she said recently that
she came out she's a big inspiration the
fat girls community she said that
uh she said that the fat gross movement
uh with
the people weren't fat and gross enough
and she was like it got taken over by
white chicks and they aren't even fat
and now you're talking about
this is true yeah talking about body
positivity yes yes
she said oh my gosh and it was here you
go
you go yeah this is helping anybody you
know the
the fat movement isn't bad enough that's
what's really funny about like the
the covet stuff in the lockdown is that
there's not going to be a body
positivity movement in a in a year
no because everyone's going to be gaunt
and like
communism yeah yeah right no businesses
no food no stimulus people are going to
go hungry
you know maybe that's the real
conspiracy because i was reading that
there's a conspiracy theory
that the global elites are like faking
everything i just want to kill poor
people guy hangs out with alex jones one
day
one night just one day and i heard it i
heard it from him and i'm like
the real conspiracy is that they're and
they're they're they're anti-woke
and they hate the body positivity
movement so they're like how do we make
americans
that makes sense take away all their
money take away all their jobs
shut down all the restaurants you can
only order things on amazon
and then all of a sudden you're going to
end up with a whole bunch of really thin
people
actually you know i know it's just being
silly but think about what might
actually happen in a year they're saying
the coveted lockdown is going to last
until quarter two or quarter three of
next year
what do you think happens you think a
lot of these you know more abundantly
obese people become just like
no i said more abundantly on purpose
they're going to be on food stamps and
more abundantly obese means you are
literally about to die from obesity
all right they'll become more sedentary
and they'll keep buying crap food with
food stamps just get sickly and fat
yeah but they're not going to have jobs
or money so they're like going to slowly
start withering away
even with yeah with the lack with kovid
sort of taking away people's jobs it
goes one way or the other same with the
trump you know whether he's gone or
whatever he's not gone it's like
with that when you take that stuff away
people either have to kind of be like
all right let me actually get my life
together now
or they or they double down on like okay
well i don't have a job and i don't have
food i guess i can double down on my
activism
because right activism has been in like
for the last four or five years it's
been
you know this stuff's been an excuse for
a lot of people to not have to do
anything like oh i couldn't you know
write that extra book i had to yell at
the cops i couldn't
well i would love to have taken that
school course but i did something better
i
argued on facebook for 45 years yeah
yeah you know that and they go that must
be nice for you to not
have to do that but i have no choice you
know i had no choice right you don't
want the
it's a perfect excuse for being lazy
it's well i mean it's a huge excuse
right i mean
activism used to be kind of hard right
yes actually you used to get arrested in
charge of crimes
well even now the da's cut you loose and
you're walking back to it so easy
remember 10 years ago when we'd see like
you'd
see some white chick like go to africa
and build a school and you'd be like oh
people kind of like roll their eyes at
that yeah
she did ten times more seriously ten ten
dude that person dude not on a plane
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
found yeah yeah no no it i don't know
how you
it's it's a multiplier effect because uh
i don't know how you do this
when when the far left activism is a net
negative they're not making things
they're destroying
things but i was i was saying 10 times
the energy put in but you're right
yeah it's negative 100. none of them do
anything but yeah
that's true that's true i mean but the
thing is you used to have to go
you go to africa you find a kid you take
your picture now you just find some guy
in brooklyn and you're like look this
guy isn't even a ceo
yeah it's the whole thing now so i think
a lot of people are gonna have to figure
out
you know what their life looks like
post-trump and you know a post covid
if you're like if you're for the you
know if you're with the government on
covet
you're with the you know government to
corporations on you know what the
how people should treat each other it's
like what is i think i think post-trump
there's going to be a lot of uh
trump-ism that's already what they're
saying yes so i'm seeing like
uh somebody tweeted you know trump's
lawsuit it's not really arguing fraud or
whatever
and then someone responded they're just
trying to keep trumpism going and i'm
like trump-ism these trumpists
yeah trumpists they actually say
trumpets yeah trump
what do you think do you think that like
trumpism is a little bit of there's no
such thing as trump
no no i'm saying like you could probably
agree that the whole world thing became
a religion for some people
yeah it is a religion for sure
non-theistic religion absolutely i would
say that for some people
donald trump is somewhat of a religion
yes yeah but cult of personality
trump's not uh you know i think a lot of
people he doesn't have as many tenants
yeah i think i think i think a lot of
the people who support trump are kind of
regular people who will roll their eyes
you know what crazy things he says i
like kurt metzger he said this because
he's like a jehovah's witness he says
the difference between the real
religions and the fake religions is or
not the real religions and the bad
religions is you actually have to do
their thing
like with christianity you kind of don't
have to do it right with with the
with trump he's like you don't really
have to do my things but in you know if
you're a part of the woke things like no
you kind of have to do the things
oh yeah so that's well it's not even
that in if you're part of the woke
religion
i imagine like if being woke and and
like showing up to
you know what have you ever seen uh
silent hill that movie
it's a video game have you ever seen
you've seen that part of it a few weeks
ago
so there's there's a part where she goes
down into this shaft and there's like
the
it's a horror movie right and there's a
bunch of nurses and they're like very
busty attractive but their faces are all
bandaged up and they're like all
twisted and they have knives and if you
make a single noise they start swinging
wildly with the knives isn't it
i imagine that what's like being woke
it's like you're in there with them
and you're like sweating and you're like
if i say
one wrong thing all of these women are
just
swinging knives at me and like slashing
throats 100 accurate that's exactly what
it's like
it is a little bit like that you know
what and that kind of like aggression
i know i'm kind of making weird
analogies here but a lot of it is just
like city chicks
stuff yeah cause if you think about it a
lot of what's happening is you you know
you have a group of like chicks or
whatever
and they'll be like you know telling
people what they should want like this
is what you should think is hot this is
what you should
want in a woman yes and you go these are
a little bit like hot girl demands
and you have not hot chicks telling them
to
yeah what's going on it's like a guy
that's poor being like you this is what
you should like in a guy and he's like
living on the street he's never had a
job
and he's smoking weed on your coach have
you ever have you
have you heard of life coaching yes so
many of these life coaches are like
not particularly successful people
therapists are all depressed trying to
tell you
what you should be doing but i think i
think uh
woke the wokeness is quite literally
social pressures from uh young's
like millennial city yeah i want to say
young because now they're in their 30s
city women like you said telling people
what they should like and the guys who
think that by agreeing with whatever
they say they'll get laid
yeah so you've got 68 percent of
millennial women are democrat
and then men are actually millennial men
are but you know evenly split between
democrat republican
i'm fairly confident you know a lot of
these like male feminists
they think they're gonna get laid like
they think just agreeing with these
women
i'm not saying literally every single
one but there's a lot of them and i i
say that specifically because there are
a lot
you know the meme reset the clock yeah
there's a lot of these male feminists
who are actually
abusers and assault these women they're
entering these spaces pretending to be
woke
because they're predators looking for
and then there's some bad ones too
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah those guys are
pretty bad
oh there are substantially worse ones i
kind of just
interrupt from the last point it's kind
of weird i was thinking about this when
people a lot of people say you know
especially with gen z like gen z is more
conservative right
and it's and it's so yeah but it's the
truth is like those words just got
changed you go
is it really the gen z is more
conservative or is it that they're like
well i know i'm not
that you know so i think a lot of these
words got changed and
you know one of the things is more
authoritarian but if you actually look
at what's being considered conservative
it's just that they've changed all the
lines and all the definitions
so gen z is only a little bit more
conservative in some areas
but they're very they're very much on
par with progress with millennials
gen z uh is slightly more conservative
in some areas than millennials but for
the most part it's
pretty much the same which put it but
that's serious because every generation
has been way more progressive than the
last
except for gen z gen z is kind of like
sort of shifted a little bit in the
direction
and i think it's because uh the left
doesn't have kids and the right does
so i i talked about this before that in
the 2000s early 2000s they said
they uh uh conservative families are
having an average uh
2.01 kids per family and liberals are
having point uh 1.7
and so add 20 years you have slightly
more conservative gen z than you have
of liberal well that accounts for some
of it but there's also like a ton of
immigrants and stuff like that so
that's true that would even that yeah to
some degree but i think it's
you know that what makes someone say
whether they're conservative or liberal
and
i think a lot of these see politics is
is the easy way to look at it it's kind
of like the ufc
like you know with sports right if
you're if you're like oh i'm gonna get
into sports like
if you're a girl that's like wants to
get into something and you want to get
into politics
it's so easy you just pick a team and
you go on this and you don't have to
really do anything right so it's an easy
thing to like get involved with
like ufc if you're going to basketball
or baseball you need to know the stats
whereas like a lot of people can just
pick it pick a thing so everything gets
looked at through that lens but
i think more so when especially when
you're looking at kids and stuff like
that
it's a lot of it is like a masculine
versus feminine feminine dynamic
masquerading as a left right dynamic
yeah absolutely i mean
sounds like something jordan peterson
would say really well yeah yeah
jordan peterson is giving uh joe biden a
run for his money and who has the better
hair plugs those guys
those guys both look like mr burns and
now they have like afros
oh my gosh we had to take it but yeah so
you know i mean like there is there's so
much
all of this stuff where it's like when
you look at like freedom safety and all
of the things that are manifesting
themselves as left right
right it's all male female well that's
that's why it's interesting that 68
and this is from i think a year so ago
from pew research 68 of millennial women
are uh democrats and then men are evenly
split
like i said probably because some guys
are just you know not really democrats
they're just predators or they're just
you know going after these women now for
sure though that weird white night
like uh phenomenon yeah it's like it's
like
they trust in god but god is that women
taking over
and it's it's almost like it's vague no
the white if i give my power to women
then everything's going to be all right
it's like
i think you're just talking about
simpsons just like i would also call
them sims
yeah they're just guys who are like i
will give you oh yeah exactly
i'll give you whatever you want and
that'll work for me and then i'm with
her
i don't know anything about her but
she's well some people aren't meant to
stray from the pack right for them it
was
you know here's what the rules are and
then they'll go okay i'll take that i
don't want to be stepping out of line
and this is what they're told to do so i
think a lot of people just and there's
people in that that
you know that there's people on all
sides that believe what they say it's
not like everyone's
right right but i think a lot of people
that are feeling like alienated from
whatever being on
a different side it's because like you
know everyone's like oh we need to be
more safe and you
everyone's feeling you know this is what
men are and they go what it's just like
all the stuff they're being told about
what like a man is or what i was talking
to
you know like a chick when she girls
will say for example like
you know men need to be more emotional
and obviously like girls don't really
want that what they
do is no dude when you start go go cry a
bunch in front of your girl see how much
she likes that
yes yes quickly she has a new guy but
they go
i was talking about this bit ago they go
every every guy like
they need to be more in touch with their
feelings they don't talk with their
friends enough about emotions and you go
no no when i hang out with my friends i
get to not talk about my advertising
right it's a reprieve because they think
about it like themselves like what do i
get from my friends and you go no no
i might i don't want to go talk to my
friends it's more important i don't want
to hear about my
five friends problems right this is like
when i get to not do that stuff yeah
we're chilling
i don't want look i deal with my own
problems i go to work oh it's
frustrating you know oh i stubbed my toe
and then you go hang out with yourself
down the half pipe fall on the halfway
slice your wrist open
and then when you're hanging with your
friends it's like not work not stressed
it's none of that
chill out yeah
yeah you don't wanna you know i don't
want to give a list of my problems i
don't want
you know my my chicken you know oh like
you and your friends you like never talk
about stuff i go
that's why we're friends for like so
long thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you